scenes can be cut out of movies for any
number of reasons sometimes they grind
the plot to a halt while other times
they clash with the tone of the rest of
the movie often they're just totally
unnecessary these deleted scenes however
are some of the greatest ever filmed
which makes it even more of a shame that
they ended up on the cutting room floor
arguably the most important and
horrifying scene in an Dimas Gettys
adaptation of it is the debut of penny
wise Stephen King's unforgettable eater
of worlds spawning a thousand memes and
a thousand more nightmares the moment
when penny wise lures georgie den burrow
into the sewers below dairy is as
terrifying as it is instantly memorable
and it's hard to imagine the situation
could have played out differently but it
turns out that machete actually directed
a surprise alternate opening for it
which ends in a very different way
while this was obviously filmed as a gag
machetes alternate opening does provoke
some interesting thoughts about the
story
if Georgie had survived penny wises
attack it's entirely possible that the
evil demons reign over the town of Derry
would have continued unchallenged after
all the murder of Georgie was the
beginning of the end of his demise even
if he didn't know it at the time when we
first meet Steve Rogers in the Avengers
he's taken out his frustration and
despair on a punching bag as memories of
his life during World War Two flashed
through his mind but there's also an
entire deleted sequence which
demonstrates just how depressed cap has
really become the scene opens with Steve
alone in his apartment watching World
War two propaganda films after pouring
through the government files of his long
gone friends he briefly considers
calling his old flame Peggy Carter but
never picks up the phone Steve then
wanders through a city filled with cell
phones and fancy cars completely lost in
the 21st century before winding up at a
cafe
mr. Aherne come be a [ __ ] he then takes
a lonely subway ride to the boxing gym
where we meet him in the actual film
it's a shame the sequence was cut from
the movies since it shows the full
extent of Steve's isolation and makes it
a more satisfying victory when he
finally finds his place in the world
Marvel movie dads are often rotten and
Thanos has got to be the worst of the
bunch
even his favorite daughter Gamora has
suffered a fair bit of abuse at his
hands
but while the relationship is incredibly
twisted the two still feel some
affection for each other an infinity war
did a good job of exploring their
complex dynamic in a short amount of
time however there's one deleted scene
that digs even deeper into their
relationship it opens in Thanos his
throne room with the mad Titan showing
his imprisoned daughter a scene from
their past back when she was his most
trusted assassin by the look of it
you seem content enough at the time
prisoner but Gomorrah explains that her
self-loathing only started to disappear
when she joined up with the guardians of
the galaxy even a guilt trip from Thanos
isn't enough to get her back on side you
had a family here that wanted you just
didn't care what happened to it while
the scene isn't exactly necessary to the
story it does give some color to one of
the movie's most fascinating
relationships a deleted scene doesn't
need to be long to be great take this
moment from spider-man to for example
the scene comes after Peter Parker has
given up on his crime-fighting career
and is ready to finally live a normal
life having thrown his suit into a
garbage can eventually the suit makes
its way to Jay jonah Jameson The Daily
Bugle z' cantankerous editor is thrilled
that spider-man has called it quits but
in this deleted scene we learned that
maybe there's a reason why Jameson
disliked Spidey so much
even though the scene is incredibly
brief it's a hysterical moment that
suggests Jamison might be a bigger
spider-man fan than he cares to admit
the weightlifting sequence is one of the
best moments from M night Shyamalan zhun
breakable it's a triumphant moment for
the self-doubting David but in one
deleted scene he gets an extra bit of
reassurance that he's really something
special after impressing his kid David
goes to visit the weight room at the
football stadium where he works and
successfully lifts nearly 500 pounds
it's a nice comic sting to close the
scene although as sham Ilan himself
pointed out it was just a bit redundant
coming straight after the basement
sequence but that doesn't mean it's not
a lot of fun Hannibal Lecter is a
stone-cold psychopath he's a genuine
monster who feeds on others both
emotionally and literally but while
serial killers aren't usually big on
feelings there's a deleted scene from
The Silence of the Lambs that shows
Hannibal is actually capable of empathy
locked away in his underworld prison
Hannibal launches into a monologue about
the psychology behind his fellow killer
Buffalo Bill how Betty wasn't born akela
carries how no he was made one through
years of systematic abuse
tellingly Hannibal isn't speaking in his
usual condescending tone you can
actually hear the sympathy in his voice
that his houses will be very small with
tiny windows no flowers no pets no toys
no son he ends his impassioned speech
with a line that is both chilling and
strangely sad how Billy wants to be
reborn Clary and he will be reborn only
segments of Hannibal speech are heard in
the movies theatrical cut but had the
original scene remained intact it might
have offered audiences a deeper look
into Bill's twisted mind and a better
understanding of Hannibal Lecter himself
captain Quint has got to be one of the
greatest movie characters of all time
played by the inimitable Robert Shaw
Quint is a salty sea dog who loves beer
hates sharks and has fun antagonizing
wealthy college boys
it soon becomes clear that there's a lot
more going on beneath Quinn strange
exterior but early in the film he's
played as a cackling coot with a bizarre
sense of humor one deleted scene from
Jaws demonstrates just how odd Quint can
be requiring some fishing line that's
strong enough to catch sharks he drops
by the local music store to buy some
piano wire there he finds a young boy
practicing the clarinet and starts the
sing-along brannad the scene doesn't
really contribute much to the film and
would have done some damage to the
story's pacing but it's a hilarious
performance from Shaw and a welcome
chance to spend some more time with
Quint one of the defining character
traits of lethal weapons Martin Riggs is
his unflinching willingness to put
himself in harm's way this is a guy
who's always hoping that somebody will
end his lonely life and his desire for
death has made all the clearer in this
deleted scene where Riggs squares off
against the schoolyard sniper Riggs gets
a call that there's a gunman firing at a
school and the SWAT team isn't going to
show up any time soon naturally he makes
his move
when he finally reaches the sniper he
doesn't hold back
yeah it's not entirely necessary to the
plots but don't pretend it's not badass
phew deleted scenes have captured the
hearts of movie lovers quite like the
jitterbug musical number that was cut
from The Wizard of Oz clocking in at six
whole minutes the dance sequence took
five weeks to rehearse and perform
costing MGM a total of $80,000 reports
suggest that the scene was ultimately
cut to reduce the film's running time
but it's also possible that the upbeat
nature of the song simply didn't fit
with the story's darker elements written
by composer Harold Arlen and lyricist II
WA Harvard the scene was based around a
pink and blue insect that caused its
victims to dance uncontrollably once
bitten although their jitterbug wasn't
included in the movie's theatrical cut
in stores its existence still remain it
just goes to show some things can't be
disposed of so easily check out one of
our newest videos right here Plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]